we sat down with one family tonight who
struggles no doubt mere
many challenges many of you are facing
sasha loftis joining us near
alta and pavilion center with more on
this story
denise and brian the parent i spoke with
tonight says her daughter will have to
cross
roads large roads like this on her way
home from school
about twice a week since the new hybrid
schedule comes with tough hours
she's one of many parents asking ccsd
for help
with safe transportation
ashton solorio is ready to be done with
distance
learning it's hard i don't like it she
can't wait to get back on campus march
22nd
but her mom danielle says the district's
hybrid schedule brings a new array of
issues we are just about .1 miles shy
of being able to be offered
transportation the sixth grader
is in cohort b so she'll get out of
class around noon on thursday and friday
these are irregular hours since her
parents both work full time
she'll have no choice but to walk two
miles home
from sig roage middle school alone now
she's required to cross you know two
major
roads you know just to get to and from
school
and you know you get that one parent or
that one driver who's in a rush
it can be catastrophic it's terrifying
danielle says her family is one of many
faced with the same situation and she's
asking ccsd leaders to step
up and offer more support what is safe
for our students you know this is
something that we've seen it every year
you know there's always accidents
so ashton and so many others across the
valley
can safely get back to the school
they've so desperately missed
the burden shouldn't be on us or the
kids and
that's where it's going
danielle and her daughter said that it's
important to remind everyone those
school zones around the valley will be
returning
for the first time in about a year so
it's something to be aware of also
another thing she mentioned to mention
again that
kids will be heading home at different
times of the day in the morning and
midday
so just a time to be aware anytime
you're driving around southern nevada
reporting live tonight sasha loftis 8
news now